I am pro intervention with respect to
Syria,
but pro intervention with the following
caveat,
I think intervention at this point is
inevitable.
I don't see how this regime,
although it's fall,
might be construed as inevitable.
That's certainly with the White House
has been saying it could still very well
carry on for at least a year if not
more.
Can you define,
define for us what I believe in this
sort of safe zone scenario for Syria,
one that is being now mooted by the
Turkish government,
uh,
which has been threatened to be imposed
by the Turkish government since last
June.
And I also would agree that there needs
to be some kind of aerial component.
I mean the rebels cannot face a tanks
and helicopter gunships which are now
firing on them alone.
There needs to be some kind of a full
scale,
a military intervention.
By that I don't mean out in occupation.
All Iraq,
I'm talking about things that are
already being put into motion are
already being considered by the United
States and by Turkey.
So an enforced no fly zone for snow
flies.
I'm to just harder you through this,
but could that be light on the sort of
Libya model where that means not just
enforcing it but actually taking out
soon air to air defense capability?
Yes,
and also,
I mean,
keep in mind a no fly zone doesn't just
necessarily bomb barracks.
In fact,
I don't think that in this case that's,
that's called for it.
Um,
it would also target the placement of
hell heavy artillery tanks.
It would also control the [inaudible]
highway,
which is the main ground transport
throughout all of Syria.
You cannot really can conduct this kind
of ground campaign against the rebels if
you can't operate on the main
thoroughfares of the country.
So yes,
it would be similar to,
to Olivia style intervention,
but not exactly.
Of course,
the two countries are vastly different
in many ways now deem your shaking your
head.
This has disastrous go.
If this option goes,
you don't know what,
what,
what the capabilities of,
of,
of the Syrian army,
we're talking about one of the mightiest
armies in the Middle East with,
with tanks and heavy alternately and,
and war ships and jet fighters.
And,
and what are you going to destroy and
how much are you going to destroy
without going into a full war with the
country?
I mean,
this is absolute disastrous option.
The intervention will,
will open the country into a,
an abyss.